hey everybody welcome back to fantasy
valley today we're starting work on the
new area in the park which is the
European area now note when I say
European I don't strictly mean a
European theme there are many things
that fit within that very broad
definition just like there are many
things that fit within a theme of
fairytale or fantasy what I'm going for
here is a European medieval fantasy like
theme it's just inspired by the general
idea but it'll hopefully come together
as a theme which is quite unique to the
look of this Park in itself in a very
similar sense to what I've done with
Asia which also kind of a blend of
different styles with a bunch of
different things thrown into the mix
this will be mostly inspired by the
medieval castles and villages in Europe
with a lot of fancy touches to it as
well and another thing which I want to
note is that because of this this is
probably the most ambitious part of the
park so far and in the end it is going
to be by far the most important one why
because this is actually the biggest
weenie in the entire park this is really
going to be the big castle which stands
in the middle of the park which you're
going to be able to see as you walk into
the main street and pretty much wherever
you are in the park it's going to be a
very iconic landmark also more or less
the big icon of the park and for that
reason I wanted to put my utmost effort
and a lot of time and pretty much quite
a bit of thought into it as well yeah I
thought about this way too long and hard
to actually make this something that
could represent fantasy Valley as a
whole and also could fit into it as a
style so what am i doing precisely here
I'm going to be making a castle and the
closest thing that I think anybody will
understand that I can compare it to is
the Disneyland castle it is a castle
with a lot of towers which you'll be
able to see from the main street it's
quite Center focused from the park so
it's very similar in that regard but I
actually would not compare this castle
that much to the Disneyland cause
the only way in which I would compare it
is in the very function of it being a
weenie of being a focal point which you
can see from the rest of the park and
which draws visitors to that certain
section and the fact that this is really
a disney castle in the sense that disney
castles are these castles that don't
really have much of a solid body to them
but are just a bunch of towers stacked
together with one very high central
tower to give the impression of a large
building even if it's built on a very
small footprint but aside from those
things style wise and just the entire
way that I wanted to go about building
this castle is very unlike I would
actually say the main inspirations in
this case were actually symbolic in the
F's language if you're Dutch you
probably know about this and if you're
not I just want to very quickly explain
it symbolic is basically a right that
the efteling is building for which
they're making a giant castle in the
middle of the park which is going to
house a dark ride and that kind of style
which has a very reddish gold ish with
copper elements that kind of color
scheme and detailing that's a kind of
style which I was very influenced by
with this castle except I wanted to big
bring it to a bigger scale and while
symbolic is very flat more horizontal
ish building I didn't want to draw the
towers a lot more here and make a very
vertical and tall building and aside
from that I would say a symbolic Oh was
the main inspiration here and I just
wanted to draw it into a more classical
fantasy tour kind of castle structure
and that's really the idea but also I
wanted to use it as a wild card to just
go crazy with the items in the game and
try whatever I could because the focus
in this building is gonna be lying super
heavily on the detail as you might
already be able to tell this thing is
going to take quite a while instead of
you know doing a couple buildings in one
episode I'm probably going to end up
doing a couple of episodes on one
building and that is even with skipping
certain parts like you just saw those
there's no way that I can do this
super quickly with the amount that I
wanted to play and add certain details
to it and I wanted to make every single
parts of the building unique and that is
what really most of the time is going to
be sunken into so as you can see with
some of these towers as well we've got
the main tower in the middle the tower
which is a square which I've already
built at this point is going to be the
tallest tower of the entire castle and
really the main well focus point of
what's really gonna draw its shape
together which has a somewhat simple
spire still made out of a different
kinds of elements which I wanted to get
in there to make the roofs not too
recognizable and standard it's got a
very small purse or a sight our attach
to it or it uses a slightly different
roof kind of structure and use a
slightly different war decorations and
that's the kind of pattern that I want
to keep going in the rest of the course
I want every single tower to be unique
and I want to have different patterns
and different details on all of the
different walls of the castle which
means that it's going to take a lot of
time to actually put all of those
details together not just to put them
together and actually make them work but
also to kind of figure out how I want to
do certain things since for many of
these things I'm just trying and
experimenting along the way as well so
yeah it will be pretty time-consuming
but I hope it'll be worth it in the end
it just means that it's gonna take quite
a few episodes to finish this thing but
I'm mostly concerned about how it's
going to look in the end and that's
pretty much what I'm working towards and
how long this Casso is gonna take I
don't really give a [ __ ] aside from it
looking good in the end that's really
the only goal which I have in mind right
now so I'm building up a little bit more
of the castle here we have that little
roof on this side of the course which is
actually quite large which is quite
similar to how the Disneyland consoles
are built up and then in front of that
we have this sort of spiral staircase
with a bunch of towers on the side I
figured it would be a fun elements to
add into this building I like the idea
of having
by rolling through parts on the car so
I'm not sure how I'm gonna be any more
of that kind of spiral elements into it
but I thought it would fit in quite well
here and if I didn't add these things I
would have had to find another way to
bulk up the cost or a bit more and add
more detail to it and I wasn't really
sure how to approach that so I ended up
just putting this staircase around the
main tower which I do kind of like and I
still had this little empty space over
here which I wasn't really doing much
with and I wanted to bring get rid a bit
of that very square boring ish shape of
the console tower so I put a little sort
of extending roof parts over there and
after that I think yeah this is good for
the time being we'll do a bit more
detailing so I wanted to make these
walls over here a little bit less boring
than they were and add a bunch of detail
to it so that's what I'm doing here and
this would also be a pretty good example
of how I want to bring out some slightly
different details on all of the
different walls of the castle I will be
using these castle walls as a base for
the wall structure on pretty much all
the sides of the console but by adding
those Brown pillars and using some other
kind of details interchangeably to add
all sorts of different textures and
colors to the walls hopefully they
should all end up a little bit different
in the end and that is what I am going
for at this point now I was adding
windows for a little bit over there by
ended up removing them and you will
actually see me place any windows on the
lower floors of this castle but you'll
probably barely see me place any windows
on this castle in general which actually
has a reason because one thing that is
going to set this thing apart from the
Disneyland castles and really makes the
obvious Happy Valley inspiration very
obvious is the fact that this color is
not going to stand on its own for many
of the Disney castles they usually are
surrounded by a lake or they have a
little grassy hill next to them but it's
just a castle on their own and to
complete focus on the castle itself and
there's nothing really attention drawing
around it
I actually want to take a different
approach with this console and one that
is very similar even if it is a
completely different style to the
centerpiece of Happy Valley in Beijing
which is that this castle is actually
going to have a village around it and
it's not going to be a village in the
fantasy land this Nealon style but it's
actually one that builds up to work the
castle so between this castle and the
path is not going to be a small hill
there's not going to be a small lake or
anything like that there's actually
going to be some houses some facades
that should hopefully in the future
connect the path a little bit more with
the console but also allow me to build a
coaster through this and have some
interaction with the scenery which I
think I'm going to explain a little bit
more basically I wanted to put a bit of
more interaction with the castle with
the paths into this build but one
problem that I kind of have with these
kinds of castles is that they're quite
closed you have love this interesting
towers and details on the top but the
bottom if you take for example the
Cinderella Castle in Disney World
there is not much of a connection
anywhere it's just straight castle walls
and the only real way in which it
interacts with the area and the paths
around it is just the fact that there's
a big attention-grabbing gates in it and
it and you can actually walk through the
castle which is probably the one saving
elements of what makes Disney castles
work so well but this is not actually a
castle which are going to be able to
walk through because it doesn't actually
lead to any new kind of area like the
Disney councils do but I still wanted to
you know draw this castle into the path
a bit more so the plan is really to
build it into a hill with the castle on
top and on the lower parts have these
houses which connects to the paths with
some shops in it or anything that you
can go into just anything that that kind
of makes it into this thing which
interacts more with the path and really
makes the path feel bit closer to the
castle but also it's a good way to get a
coaster in here which yes I I do want to
get some coaster castle interaction here
I'm not really sure how well it's going
to work out
it's a bit of a risk it is playing it a
bit more safe to just put no coaster
interaction with a console and just
focus on the console itself because they
can easily be very distracting from each
other but in this case I really want to
try and experiment with having a coaster
run around and through the castle so
there will be a small space between
where this console is going to stand and
where the lower houses alongside the
paths are going to stand and between
that the coaster should come up with its
lift hill and do some elements around
the castle and interact with all of the
scenery and hopefully the parts as well
in the future which might sound like a
crazy stupid idea but it basically just
boils down to I have wanted to get too
many elements into this one part of the
park it is actually quite similar to how
a coaster dips straight in front and
through the landscape of the Asian
buildings as well as with the paths
which are in the foreground it's very
similar to that kind of idea but just in
a different theme and in a more slightly
more complex layouts I would reckon in
this case so yeah that is the plan for
this build I want to catch up a little
bit with the buildings that I'm doing
here I wanted to make another Tower and
this one originally started out as a
tower which was heavily inspired by one
of the built one of the towers in
symbolic err I ended up not really
liking that idea very much so I put a
bell tower on the top of it made it
quite a bit more lengthy and a bit more
of a slim tower design and put a dome on
top of it and a bunch of details just to
make it look a bit more pretty and that
kind of represents a bit of a
counterweight to the extremely tall
tower on the front and makes it look a
bit more like a disney castle if you're
looking straight from the front of the
building so with that finished I wanted
to move on to probably the biggest
challenge of making this castle which
was giving this castle a bit of a body
like I said before the Disney castles
are kind of not really castles in a
sense that they're just a collection of
towers
and they don't really have any kind of
distinctive body like a real castle
would have its huge galleries and [ __ ]
and rooms everywhere a Disney course was
just a collection of towers on a small
footprint and if you were to remove them
you don't really you're not really left
with much I guess the only exception
would be the castle in Shanghai is
Disneyland but that one is actually
exceptionally bulky compared to the
other castles out there and I wanted to
give this console quite like a bulky
shape as well and actually make it
possible to build something in the
console because hopefully I could either
put a cool attraction in the console or
put the cue for the coaster in the
console or perhaps even have the coaster
go through the console as a dark ride
elements I'm not really sure what I'm
gonna do with that but I wanted to make
this quite bulky since it'll also have
to transition with a village around it
and the main inspiration was the big
centerpiece of happy valley beijing
which also has this very large shape
which the coaster interacted with the
lot and the problem was how do I make
this console look like it's actually a
proper console and like it actually has
the proper like body and size of a real
castle without actually making it look
like a boring real castle just has well
straight roofs and flat roofs and boring
stuff which I didn't really want to get
in here so the idea that I went with in
the end would was to add a big dome at
the back of the building which you don't
really actually see that well if you
approach the castle from the straight
front you pretty much just see the
coasters or the towers but if you
actually look at the cost from the side
or from the back the dome is actually a
pretty recognizable and large feature
and it was just a way that I figured I
could make this castle give a very large
footprint to it while at the same time
not being not ending up with this very
large flat boring roof on the top of the
castle
and the dome as such is kind of like one
big tower detail for it there were a
couple of challenges with making the
dome though because as you can see it
takes quite a lot of wood to actually
put the large dome structure together I
was also not too sure how I would
actually feature the details on top of
the dome whether I wanted to have some
windows on it and how I wanted to put
the entire thing together so that just
took a lot of trial and error and
looking at the dome and seeing what ways
actually liked it in the end I decided
to leave the dome quite empty and not
put many windows on it just leave it
with the riches like the golden riches
that are decoration on the side right
now but what I didn't want to put on top
of it is a small cupola which it's
pretty much just a standard kind of
thing for many domes but this one's
pretty big considered to the size of the
dome itself and it's just about the size
of the other towers of the building so
looking from many kinds of different
angles it looks like pretty much just
one extra tower on the castle and that
was really the effect which ours hoping
to achieve here so um I'm pretty happy
with how it turned out I guess in the
end though the dome is really bulky and
it does make the building quite heavy
looking and the thing is I'm gonna have
to wait with judgment as to how it
really looks because I won't be able to
finish the building in just this video
so it won't be a great representation of
what the building as a whole looks like
in the end
so whether the dome can stay this big or
whether I want to scale it down a little
bit pretty much depends on how it's
gonna look in the end but I'm really
happy with how the detailing on it and
the small cupola on top of it turned out
fits in pretty well with the style and
it's a great way to get some extra
golden elements into the building I
wanted to get as many of these golden
accents and detailing into the building
as I could but it's it's pretty tough to
do that kind of thing since there aren't
really many items in the game with these
golden textures most of them are in
scenery items and/or
ten pieces and you kind of have to come
up with some ways to make these funds in
pieces not recognizable as fountain
pieces and make them fit into the shapes
and things that you're trying to make
with them so here I was using this
little pillar to get some small golden
details on a railing on top of the wall
here and the circular tower elements
actually felt like a pretty useful thing
to make some round railings which
together with the small golden pillars
hopefully should make for a pretty neat
railing in the end I wasn't too sure
about how I was going to do the windows
on these walls so I was playing with
that a little bit in the beginning and
none of the things which I went for
really ended up looking that's good
so I just went for the boring double
pillars in the middle with a simple
gothic window and that's kind of a
placeholder but I might just keep it it
I might just keep it that way kind of
depends on how good it looks in the end
but so far this is like the big
important curved wall that I wanted to
use on this side and next I wanted to
move on to one of the last towers of
this episode using the wall texture
thing that actually took from the first
tower of the entire castle just because
it's pretty simple to make but also
because I hadn't used it much at this
side of the building and I think it good
and it could fit in pretty well and the
top of the tower where I have the spire
I definitely wanted to get and as unique
spire as I could so far so first of all
I wanted to make some yeah which you
really call it some very large cornice
like pieces to make the top of the tower
before I went into the roof and these
were all well still pretty easy to make
and quite similar and fitting in with
the style of the rest of the building so
far but for the roof of this I wanted to
do something different than what I'd
done with the tower is so far and
actually make the roof myself instead of
trying to blend different roof pieces
together to make a unique style and here
I really wanted to
make a square shaped kind of spire roof
with a nice little needs top on top of
it so I had to make that myself and just
make it out of wooden planks which is
not the most neat looking texture might
get back to that but I'm probably gonna
leave it this way I could actually make
the texture a bit better by just using
the wooden brackets which are slightly
smaller and have a bit more of a single
type roof texture to them but that would
mean a whole lot of faces which are
quite unnecessary and do add up quite a
lot so if you're trying to make an
entire roof with them on the four sides
so I ended up not doing that and just
going for the blanks again same also
goes for the dome I wanted to do it as
low poly as I could
so that's that roof over there which is
quite a bit different than the other
towers which I had so far I do like it
there's a many different colors and
textures in all of the roofs most of
them still are these simple castle roofs
but the green domes were super handy in
this case and being able to make your
own shapes of roofs with wooden planks
even if it is something that takes a lot
of effort is something that is still
quite fun to do and mess around the
different roof shapes so I will be doing
that a little bit more in the future as
well the first building in which I did
it as well being this building but I
wanted to do it in a much more simple
way and just because I wanted to get a
very vertical tall spire on this
building I played around with the
in-game roof for one second but figured
nah that's not gonna do I need some kind
of a REIT or narrow aspire on this
building to really bring it to life and
yeah decided to make my own roof again
which is super simple this time but
something in a shape which you don't
really have in the game which I really
didn't want to have and where most of
the appeal of the spire is really in the
fact that it doesn't look like any of
the other spires on the castle we might
bump into some issues at the end of this
build once every roof combination has
already been used I'm trying to come up
with new ways
make these things but there are endless
types of spires and there's a lot of fun
to be had with them so as some of the
very last things that I wanted to do
here I wanted to change the detail on
these things a little bit since it felt
a bit too dark and bit too detailed
compared to the rest of the build so I'm
decided to replace a couple of wooden
pillars with some concrete ones there to
blend them in with the texture a little
bit more and move on to work on the very
last tower on this side and pretty much
the tower that finishes off the front of
the castle so even though practically
nothing about the consoles really
finished at this point and I haven't
even started work on the coaster or the
buildings around this the front facade
of the castle and the way that this
castle is going to look once you
approach the park from the entrance and
see the castle in a distance in the main
street it's pretty much finished and it
pretty much does look the way that it's
going to be looking in the distance if
you've you it from the front perspective
so it's a pretty good measurement of
what it's going to look like in the end
but it's definitely very very
work-in-progress lots of things are
going to be changing and going to be
added in the future so that's something
to look out for but anyway that's it for
this time-lapse so thank you guys for
watching and hope to see you guys next
time
[Music]
[Music]